[Musique]
c'est parti ce soit le nombre de
départements en zone rouge passe de 55 à
69 pour ces zones plusieurs seuils
d'alert sont créés ce qui implique une
série de nouvelles restrictions
l'attention se focalise en particulier
sur les grandes villes 8 dont paris sont
en zone d' alerte renforcée dans ces
villes à partir de lundi des bars et
restaurants devront fermer au plus tard
à 22 heures le taux de reproduction du
virus
ce facteur 2 3 voire au delà ce que vous
voyez sur ce graphe au-dessus de 1
ces facteurs est remis le reste peu au
dessus de 1 par des patients co lead
dans nos réanimation de 950 patients
atteints de corona virus dans les
réanimations française rouler elio le
signe qui rappelle de manière pas très
délicate
ça m'inquiétait pas que ce masque il
faut le porter donc de dunes et jusqu'au
menton et les surprises car à mon avis
elle va le porter quand les pennois par
ailleurs gouverneur et sait comment
savoir vous amis c'est assez c'est assez
dramatique en fait c'est une hécatombe
ça se passe au sud de l'australie dans
une baie reculé de tasmanie vous savez
ils sont plusieurs centaines de ses
terres bloqué dans cette bécane passe
étroite ces images aériennes donnent une
idée de l'ampleur de la situation
il y en a des dizaines éparpillés sur
deux bancs de sable quand on se
rapproche on comprend la difficulté des
sauveteurs parce que la plupart des
manifs air ne sont accessibles que par
la mer ça c'est un crocodile à loisy
ça veut dire que l'animal a souffert il
a été ligotés bâillonnés les yeux bandés
pour éviter le stress des tapis t vif
vous fabriquez cette paix on n'est pas
du tout pour 25 animaux ont pu être
sauvées 90 sont morts nouveau coup de
massue ce matin quand deux cents
nouveaux spécimens ont été repérés à une
dizaine de kilomètres de là dans deux
autres baies cela serait très mal en
point ou mort cela porte donc à 470 le
nombre de dauphins pilote échouées dans
la région en quelques jours mme affret
jamsi la fin enfin j'en ai eu un quand
j'avais j'étais plus jeune et je leur
mets une laisse pour les sorties repas
qui restent toute la journée dans leur
cage
d'accord la tendresse pour pas qu'ils se
carapate oui non mais comme sa salle ar
l'esprit bien sûr chiens chats merde
excréments petite trotte 2
chaud
le parfum de l'espace mais oui c'est pas
une blague à odos pas aux soldes
alors lorsqu'on interroge le nez qui a
conçu cette fragrance
il parle d'une à d'un parfum un peu amer
brûlé un peu enfumée et on sent bien et
dans les landes dans village
est ce que c'est normal d'avoir des gaz
c'est parfaitement normal et
physiologiques oui quelle quantité de
gaz est il normal de produire chaque
jour sur le plan du nombre de
flatulences on donne un chiffre de 15
mais vous imaginez que c'est aussi très
variable selon les jambes et en termes
de volumes de gaz produit par l'intestin
on est sur une fourchette qui va de un
demi litre à 1 litre et demi de gaz par
jour et par des mines
on est vraiment dans une nouvelle guerre
spatiaux publicitaires et les russes ne
sont pas en reste car eux aussi
eh bien il envisage d'utiliser leurs
satellites pour projeter l'année
prochaine depuis le ciel les logos des
marques qui seront donc visibles depuis
la terre je vous promets c'est donc une
nouvelle forme de pollution visuelle qui
risque d'altérer encore un peu plus
elisabeth la contemplation des étoiles
hui lettre
grâce au wi sainte héros patrick doit
rester zen même devant des groupes un
peu pompette qui raffole du sex-appeal
de son uniforme bon succès on pourrait
croire que la fin de l'été rime avec la
fin des galipettes et bien pas du tout
nous dit la science ce serait même le
contraire
il y a les faits l'automne est par
exemple la saison la plus fertile en
particulier les mois de novembre et
décembre avec des taux de natalité
record 9 mois plus tard c'est aussi la
période durant laquelle on voit le plus
d'internautes passé de célibataire en
couple sur facebook ça ce sont les faits
plus en plus comme styliste qui sait
tout le monde a bel âge encore
leonardo dansant
dans les milieux de peinture
une ride on me dit qu'on a pour vous ce
message de didier bourdon de paris non
surtout pas d'abord il ya les hormones
l'automne est la saison pendant laquelle
le niveau de testostérone serait le plus
élevé mais aussi les effets de la baisse
des températures sur notre cerveau les
chercheurs ont montré que pour résumer
avoir froid déclenché un désir ardent de
chaleur sous toutes ses formes
tous fait tomber ben pour faut qu'on
puisse voir ce que c'est pourtant ils
avaient des formes intéressant de
l'activité d'auteurs compositeurs les
hyper solitaire et la être enrichi par
les autres soutient depuis même se
satisfaire quelqu'un c'est le metteur en
scène j'aime bien cette idée mais bon
moi je suis tout seul et je peux pas me
satisfaire
don cherry non on est que nous trois
donc tu vois nous trois plus déjà un
homme en plus je pense qu'il est
incessant
on vide trois femmes ensemble depuis des
années à presque 20 ans plus les chiens
sont des filles est alors y'a juste
gribouille à sunnyvale et olia couper
les coûts ni trop la castré s'te plaît
attention merci joli programme c'est
dans un matin dans un instant bonne
journée à ben beh oui bien sûr bonne
journée sur france 2